if you traveled 10,000 years into the
future what would planet Earth look
like would most of its surface be
covered in
volcanoes or would it be frozen in
ice what if you traveled even further to
1 million years in the future would all
of the oceans have
evaporated or would it have become one
giant water
world okay now what about 1 billion
years would there be any humans
left or would they have settled in other
parts of the
Galaxy this is what if and here's what
would happen if you traveled 1 billion
years into the
future
let's face it the chances of any humans
being around to greet you when you
arrive 1 billion years into the future
are pretty
low several key existential threats face
the human race and if we want to be
around in 1 billion years we'll need to
endure them all we've seen how much
we've struggled to come together just to
survive a global pandemic so how do we
have any chance of enduring the threats
of climate change overpopulation Global
nuclear war killer asteroids and comets
Natural Ice Ages and the sun getting a
whole lot
hotter well let's take a look into the
future and find
out just under 10,000 years from now
we're going to run into a big problem
called the DECA millennium bug in the
year 10,000 ad software encoding the ad
calendar year won't encode dates with
more than four decimals remember y 2K
yeah it's just like that except
hopefully we won't Panic as much this
time
around on the bright side in 10,000
years genetic differences and traits
between humans will no longer be
Regional traits like skin and hair color
will be evenly distributed around the
world maybe that will help us all get
along
finally
20,000 years into the future none of the
current languages will be recognizable
future languages will only contain 1% of
the core vocabulary words of their
present day
counterparts 50,000 years from now will
Mark a new glacial period for the Earth
which will start a new Ice
Age Niagara Falls will have eroded into
Lake Erie
completely and interestingly a full day
on Earth will also increase by 1 second
at this point in time so much more time
for
activities in
250,000 years the LOI volcano will rise
above the water to form a new island in
Hawaii and in 500,000 years it's likely
that an asteroid with a diameter greater
than 1 k ometer will hit Earth unless we
can prevent
it the resulting crater will be no less
than 400 km across it will start fires
all over the planet and make the air
unbreathable so there's something to
look forward
to and in case that's not enough in 1
million years we'll likely have another
super volcano eruption large enough to
spew out
3200 cubic kilm of Ash it would produce
enough lava to fill 75% of the Grand
Canyon this would be similar to the Toba
eruption that almost wiped out Humanity
70,000 years
ago oh and the nearby star Beetle juu
will have exploded into a Supernova by
this
time making it visible from Earth even
during the
[Music]
daytime
in 2 million ad Humanity will have
settlements throughout the solar system
this also means that if populations on
different planets have remained separate
humans may have evolved into other
species adapted to their specific
World in 10 million years a huge part of
Eastern Africa will break off forming a
new ocean basin in 50 million years
Africa will collide with Eurasia closing
off the Mediterranean Sea and a new
mountain range will form between the two
land masses this mountain range may
include a mountain taller than Mount
Everest out in space Mars will collide
with its
Moon resulting in it developing a ring
system like
[Music]
Saturn's
in 60 million years the Canadian and
American Rockies will have eroded
entirely in 80 million years all
Hawaiian Islands will be below the
water in 100 million years an asteroid
similar to the one that killed the
dinosaurs 66 million years ago will
likely hit Earth one that is 10 km
wide in 250 million years all of Earth's
continents will be fused together like
Pangia except this time it will be
called Pangia Ultima but don't get too
attached to it because in 400 to 500
million years Pangia Ultima will
separate
again in 500 to 600 million years a
gamma ray burst will likely occur with
within 6,500 Lighty years from Earth if
it strikes Earth it could damage the
ozone layer and trigger a mass
extinction 600 million years from now
the moon will be so far from Earth that
total solar eclipses will no longer be
possible and the sun's increasing
Luminosity will have raised temperatures
on Earth so much that it could halt
plate tectonics movement
in 800 million years carbon dioxide
levels will drop dramatically and
photosynthesis will no longer be
possible free oxygen and ozone will
disappear from the atmosphere and
complex life on Earth will
die and finally in 1 billion years the
sun's Luminosity will have increased by
10% and the average temperature on Earth
will be
47° C our atmosphere will feel like a
damp greenhouse and our oceans will
evaporate leaving just pockets of water
at each of the
[Music]
poles when you arrive here in your time
machine be mentally prepared to take it
in a planet Earth that looks nothing
like the one you
remember the human race will be
gone hopefully living its best life on
some other far-off
planet because of the intense heat lack
of water and lack of breathable air
Earth will be
uninhabitable so you probably shouldn't
stay too
long so this marathon of what if
episodes focuses on living in different
eras in the history of the world world
that trip into the future started out
cool but by the end left me a bit sad
for this planet once the most beautiful
thing in the universe reduced to a dry
lifeless
Rock later on in the show we'll give you
a different perspective on the history
of Earth we'll travel 1 billion years
into the past but right now let's take a
pit stop on the way there and see what
Earth was like just 300 million years
ago who was living where your backyard
is right now millions of years ago Earth
looked very different all the continents
were fused into one teaming with life
both beautiful and
terrifying when you think of prehistoric
times you might picture a T-Rex
rampaging through the jungle with its
razor sharp teeth but even before the
dinosaurs there were other giant
creatures ruling the Earth yeah welcome
to the peran period this epic started
300 million years ago back then our
planet had one supercontinent Pangia
surrounded by a world ocean called
panthalassa the perian period began at
the end of an ice age when temperatures
were much cooler than today then during
early peran days Earth warmed to a lush
environment with a diversity of plants
and a rapid evolution of insect and
animal life only as you probably know
everything is Ever Changing on our Blue
Marble over the next 50 million years
Earth kept growing hotter and drier
eventually the most deadly event in the
history of our planet wiped out nearly
everything that ever lived here
scientists called this event the great
dying and it was the most catastrophic
mass extinction of the Earth has ever
seen and the Earth has seen five of them
but before we get to all this Doom and
Gloom let me take you on an Epic Journey
back in time here in the peran period
some of the most incredible species that
roamed our young Planet are about to
emerge if you could time travel nearly
300 million million years into the past
you'd land smack dab in the middle of
the supercontinent
Pangia Earth's smaller continents would
have just finished colliding with each
other to form this enormous land mass
taking up onethird of the planet's
surface there was likely less oxygen in
the air than there is now but you still
might be able to breathe oh and bring a
jacket because it would likely be chilly
with some areas averaging no more than a
Brisk 4°
C but don't worry things will soon start
heating up by the end of the early peran
the Ice Age was on its way out and
Pangia was becoming a lush
world plants and animals started to
thrive this was a volcanic World violent
eruptions changed the climate shaped the
landscape and paved the way for
evolution when giant swamp forests began
drying out plant life had to adapt and
so 290 million years ago Earth saw the
very first seed bearing plants called
gymnosperms these plants carried seeds
on their cones and they spread across
the superc continent like
wildfire the ancient evergreen forest of
the early peran was hiding something
familiar just like today you could find
cicas and beetles piercing and sucking
on the plants and the cutest of them all
cockroaches only these weren't the
Cockroaches you know today these
prehistoric Vermin were gigantic the
size of
birds but despite their size cockroaches
never ruled prehistoric land and that's
good news am I right no something much
more fascinating was roaming Pangia the
now extinct ancestor of primitive
mammals
dimetrodon this animal was as
fascinating as it was
terrifying encountering a dimetrodon
would be quite a sight to behold this
ancient lizard grew to 5 m long and
weighed 225
kg it had a large sail running down its
spine scientists think this sail helped
the reptile regulate its body
temperature soaking up water warmth
during the daytime and dissipating
excess heat during the cooler nights it
would walk toward you like a crocodile
and act like a total Menace dimetrodon
was an apex predator of its time watch
out for a mix of sharp and flat teeth
that would slice you open and grind you
up in the middle perian period other
mammal-like reptiles took over the
planet
therapsids they had strong jaws with
sharp teeth and a somewhat upright
stance thanks to their legs being
situated underneath their bodies
therapsid reptiles varied from the 5 m
long likely omnivorous dudosa surus to
the five times smaller meing
lops you could meet plenty more
therapsids if you stuck around for
another 20 million
years during the middle perian period
Earth kept getting hotter the average
global temperature on Pangia grew to
about 25° C and volcanoes were spitting
greenhouse gases out into the atmosphere
due to the changing climate sea levels
were shifting but marine life found ways
to thrive if you were to take a dip in
the prehistoric super ocean you'd be
swimming alongside ancient sharks and
bony primitive fish many more complex
marine species came and went as the
environment kept
changing in the late perian period you
could have a friendly encounter with
another reptile
lystrosaurus these looked like a cross
between a lizard and a pig but unlike
all the scary prehistoric monsters out
there lystrosaurus was a herbivore it
was just 1 M long and had powerful front
legs for burrowing soon another cute
mamal likee lizard evolved the
codon the codon looked like a giant
rodent it was about 1 M long had
whiskers and fed on small animals and
insects now during this time something
bad was brewing in the air a large
amount of volcanic activity was
displacing oxygen from the atmosphere
scientists think there was as little as
10 % oxygen in the air compare that to
21% today you'd have a hard time
breathing in that environment and the
temperature kept rising and Rising with
an average temperature of about 28° cus
this Lush prehistoric world was turning
into an
oven all good things must come to an end
and sadly this period came to a
particularly brutal one about 252
million years ago about 90% of all plant
and animal life was wiped out this
tragic moment is called the Great dying
and it was Earth's most devastating mass
extinction event scientists still debate
what caused this catastrophic Extinction
most theories suggest it was the result
of explosive volcanic activity as huge
volcanic eruptions swept the continent
massive amounts of Ash were Unleashed
into the atmosphere so much Ash that it
blocked out most if not all of the
incoming sunlight and with no sunlight
global temperatures dropped suddenly
plants couldn't perform their
photosynthetic processes and died off
and without plants the very basis of
their food chain animals soon
followed things got worse before they
got better because of all the carbon
dioxide emitted during the volcanic
eruptions global temperatures rose again
and not just to where they were but
higher much higher and this caused the
super ocean to lose most of its oxygen
and unable to breathe a majority of the
perian sea animals perished eventually
over 95% of marine species and More than
70% of land animals became
extinct human beings have existed for
300,000 years and have managed to live
in many unstable
environments we've survived ice ages
devastating pandemics and world
wars but how would we fare even further
back in time what about 400 million
years ago when deadly marine life
dominated our oceans and creatures on
land were practically
non-existent let's imagine your what if
time machine happened to break down
right at this moment trapping you in the
devonian
period What would life be like where
would you live and how long could you
last this is what if and here's what
would happen if you lived in the
devonian
period
Stroke of Luck our time machine stops
you on land at this point in time 85% of
the Earth was comprised of ocean only
two supercontinents existed 600 million
years ago gondwana and
larusa gondwana had a massive mountain
range similar to the Himalayas which
slowly eroded washing sediments into the
ocean these sediments provided Nutri
nuut that allowed marine life to
flourish giving rise to the devonian
period okay enough background our first
step for survival is to seek
shelter in the early devonian period
trees and plants had not yet evolved but
there's lots of moss the land was Barren
mars-like and surrounded by water you
might need to get a little creative to
build
shelter if humans actually evolved in
this period they would likely be naked
with little material to make clothes or
maybe we would develop a new fashion
line made of moss seashells and
Fishbones ooha La how devonian
Chic speaking of Fishbones you'd want to
be very careful about fishing many scary
sea creatures would be happy to eat you
like placoderms a species of armored
fish with huge sharp Jaws that could
easily make you
bite-sized in the early devonian period
placoderms were the apex predator and
would grow up to 10
m let's say you got lucky and actually
caught a fish without being eaten
yourself in the
process how would you cook it with no
trees for fuel you'd have to find some
very dry moss and start rubbing some
rocks together
luckily the climate was pretty warm
meaning you wouldn't freeze at night but
with very little kindling available you
might be better off sticking to a raw
diet of mollusks and other early
arthropods you'd also have to move
around a lot to keep finding these
Critters so be prepared to do a lot of
walking H I can see you're getting a
little tired and bored of existing out
there let's fast forward another 40
million years
toward the late devonian period this
period is also known as the devonian
extinction but don't worry it could
actually be a really good time for you
Fearless traveler since by this point
almost 79 to 87% of all existing species
were wiped out but what could cause such
a
catastrophe scientists believe it was
the evolution of plants vascular plants
began dominating the environment
including trees Ferns and flowering
plants their Roots broke up the rocky
ground and released nutrients and
minerals in the water these nutrients
fed algae which multiplied rapidly and
produced greedy bacteria that fed on
oxygen many regions of the ocean became
anoxic zones and much of the marine life
died off due to the lack of oxygen and
with more air in the atmosphere some sea
creatures slowly adapted and made their
way way to
shore so you can breathe easier knowing
there are less predators in the water
but look out for your new neighbors on
land these land dwellers known as lobins
were the early ancestors of amphibians
and all four-legged vertebrates in fact
the devonian period got its name from
the fossils of lopin found in Devon
England in 2004 a lopin fossil was found
in the Canadian Arctic known as the the
talic which is considered to be the
species between fish and landd dwelling
tetrapod it had a crocodil like head
bony fins sharp teeth and a flat body
almost 3 m long its fins had partial
wrists allowing it to crawl on land so
if I were you I would quickly hide if I
saw a talic coming my way the other
dominant species were cartilagenous fish
with skeletons covered in you get IC
cartilage these are the ancestors of
sharks and Rays but you don't have to
worry about sharks oh no there's
something far bigger and scarier I'd
keep my distance if you happen to see a
Dunkle osus swimming
around these were the deadliest
predators of the devonian age with thick
bony plates covering their skulls and
razor sharp Jaws some would grow up to
10 m in Long length their jaws were
strong enough to Chomp right through
another
Dunkleosteus with few fish left because
of plants hogging the oxygen these
placoderms were starving and desperate
enough to eat each other so be very
careful where you
bathe with more trees and plants
emerging in your environment you could
finally create some helpful tools like
Spears fishing hooks and
rope you could improve your your diet
and maybe become a vegetarian and you
could fashion some new clothes that
aren't so irritatingly itchy by the late
devonian period you might even be able
to build yourself a treehouse in the
arch opterus the first tree on earth
which grew up to 30 m tall with the
trunk 3 m wide this may be nice for a
while but if you think the devonian
period is easy you might want to plan a
hasty exit before the Cretaceous Period
rolls around
you know one of the big trends these
days has women asking men how often we
think about ancient Rome and
surprisingly for women I guess it turns
out that men think about ancient Rome
quite a bit not me I mean what are the
Romans ever done for us apart from the
aqueducts and
sanitation the roads the medicine the
education the public health and the
wine okay Mark me down as thinking about
Rome some of the time here are another 7
Minutes of ancient Rome for you
guys throughout history there have been
many incredible civilizations that have
shaped the way we live today one was
ancient Rome a once Majestic and
thriving City whose strong foundations
live on to this day yet despite all its
grandeur life as an average citizen in
ancient Rome was hard and
unforgiving what strange Customs did the
Romans
have what was the life expectancy of an
average
citizen and what did the Romans do for
fun this is what if and here's what
would happen if you lived in ancient
Rome let's imagine you woke up some time
between 27 BCE and 180 CE the Golden Age
of
Rome known in Latin by the Romans as Pax
Romana or Roman peace this epic began
when Augustus came into Power after his
father the infamous Julius Caesar was
assassinated with Augustus on the throne
Rome began a period of Rapid
development at its peak it was home home
to over 1 million people it was a truly
Golden Era of architecture science art
entertainment and economic growth it was
a time of peace and
prosperity if you were Rich
than okay so what's the catch well
unless you were part of the 1% that
controlled 16% of Rome's wealth life was
tough as a citizen up to 50% of all
Roman children died before the age of 10
and most adults were lucky if they lived
long enough to see their 50s even though
things were peaceful battles still
happened and soldiers were in demand
Roman armies at this point were largely
made up of volunteers who were hoping
for a better chance at life most
soldiers came from the poorest social
class and were stationed at the borders
of the Empire where the most trouble was
was expected as a soldier you were able
to settle in the land where you were
stationed once you retired and if you
were particularly good with a sword or a
bow you might be handpicked to join the
Special Forces designed to protect the
Emperor or maybe to climb the ranks as a
gladiator they were treated like
celebrities well at least the ones that
survived with a large portion of the men
away from home working as soldiers women
gained more autonomy during this period
serving important roles as City
councilors lawyers teachers and more
some women were even
Gladiators however the men in the family
still had the privilege of handling the
matters of property and
finance most of the poor lived in cheap
wooden houses many of them lived in the
city slums where crime was rampant you
might find the emperor augustus' police
force or cohortes Urban a patrolling
some parts of the city but generally the
poorer areas were Lawless and
dangerous whether you were a soldier
philosopher or Senator most Romans ate a
similar diet of bread cheese grapes nuts
olives and meat if you could afford it
you could eat out at one of the many
bakeries in the city to wash things down
you'd have the option of thick milk
watered wine or fruit juice that doesn't
sound too bad to me after lunch many
Romans went to the bath house to swim
play sports bathe or get a massage and
dinner was just a few hours later around
4:00 or 5:00 p.m. in the afternoon okay
where do I sign up while many Romans had
this luxury a large portion of them were
slaves or clients for Rich families
in this Patron client system people were
sold and forced to help with all kinds
of work from hard menial labor to highly
skilled jobs like teachers accountants
and doctors if they were lucky their
patrons would give them a good dinner
and they would go home with pockets full
of food and if they did really well they
would eventually be freed some poor
people were desperate enough to sell
their children in times of hardship
speaking of hardship if you needed to
use the washroom you could visit one of
Rome's public toilets housing over 10
toilet seats out in the open oh that's
intimate these weren't exactly the
cleanest toilets and instead of toilet
paper Romans had a stick with a sponge
at the end that they would
share uh I'll stick with my bedet please
oh and when it was time to clean up many
Romans used urine from humans or animals
to decontaminate surfaces treat
infections and even to wash their
laundry it might sound strange but Ura
in urine breaks down into ammonia a
strong cleaning agent found in most
cleaning supplies
today and if you happened to get sick
with epilepsy you might be prescribed
some gladiator's blood or liver to
consume uh thanks but no thanks Doc if
you managed to save up a little money
you could go shopping at the Tran Market
the first ever mall in the world or if
you were craving more excitement why you
not in the how about a chariot race at
the circus Maximus or an epic Gladiator
battle maybe some theater and for the
budget-minded there were plenty of
public executions to go around
okay power up the what if time machine
because today you're traveling back to
witness the most radical changes ever
known in Earth's history you'll watch
our planet give birth to strange new
animals and see continents taking shape
we're going to the time that defines our
existence the Paleozoic
Era but how would your body react to the
new
climate what kind of creatures would you
eat and how hot would the planet get
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you live in the Paleozoic
Era the Paleozoic Era began
530 million years ago when the earth
woke up from an ice age
the era lasted for
289 million years but you might not even
last 5 minutes in this climate but hey
if you're as resilient as the life in
these Waters you just might stay alive
in these oceans life has the perfect
space to begin and like all great things
it started
small
good luck trying to find a meal 543
million years ago all life on Earth
lived below a thick layer of mud on the
sea floor but don't get out your Lobster
bib yet the only things you'll find here
are microbes ooh so
chewy your menu won't be getting any
bigger for a few million years until the
Cambrian
explosion the big event that would
Kickstart life on
Earth the cyano bacteria would pump more
oxygen into the atmosphere making it
easier for you to breathe so take a deep
breath and enjoy life on this doomed
[Applause]
continent During the tivis period
485 million years ago you would watch
North America and Europe merge to become
the super continent known as
gondwana now grab your parka because as
this land mass moves over the South Pole
a massive Ice Age would spread across
the globe under the water jawless fish
would roam the sea dominating the ocean
algae and sponges would begin living on
coral reefs and back on land the first
plants would take root but 80% of the
life in Shallow Seas would die as sea
levels plummet when the new Ice Age
[Music]
begins starting about
444 million years ago you would see the
glaciers melt this event would create a
climate similar to what we have now the
ocean would be full of sea scorpions the
size of dogs so look out these
opportunistic Predators make confuse you
with
[Music]
dinner in the devonian period three
continents blanketed the planet 419
million years ago much of earth's land
mass remained
underwater you would need to live near
the shoreline to harvest the resources
you need to stay alive since trees would
be covering the world for the first time
you could build shelter and even start a
fire and with the soil rich in nutrients
you could begin to farm plants but while
you would rule the land as an apex
predator the ocean would belong to the
early sharks and they look
hungry
[Music]
travel back 358 million years ago and
you would see life near the equator
would Thrive while the rest of the world
would experience deadly temperature
changes the first reptiles would start
appearing look out for that
ofadon they can grow almost three M tall
even dragonflies can have wingspans of
75 centimet well one of those could feed
you for a
while okay all the changes we saw have
led to this event the peran period about
299 million years ago almost every land
mass on Earth had merged into the
supercontinent known as
Pangia this massive land stretched from
pole to pole with vast deserts in the
center the wild temperature changes
would kill amphibians but don't worry
you wouldn't be alone here the aops
would Tower over you standing 2 m tall
this lizard-like creature devoured its
prey whole if you keep out of its way
you might enjoy the new oxygen levels
thanks to more trees sprouting up
everywhere but you would see a violent
end to this period whether it's meteors
exploding volcanoes or methane clouds
96% of all life on Earth would die out
the highest Extinction rate ever
known I never realized how dangerous the
peran period was not a lot of firsthand
accounts available to read about it now
if you enjoyed that trip through the
Paleo zoic era well in a couple of weeks
we'll have a new video coming out taking
a deeper dive into the Cambrian Period
the first real explosion of
multicellular life on Earth be sure to
hit subscribe and you'll be notified the
moment the video comes out okay enough
about the Permian and the Cambrian we
all know why you came here today the
Carboniferous period yeah let's take a
trip into this period the one that
birthed
Pangia just remember to take an oxygen
regulator a sweater and a giant fly
swatter you'll see what I mean over 300
million years ago before the age of
giant dinosaurs Earth was covered with
giant
insects imagine a world where
dragonflies are the size of crows and
millipedes are as long as
cars welcome to the Carboniferous
period why were insects so enormous
during during this
time what did oxygen have to do with it
and why did these insects go
extinct this is what if and here's what
the Earth looked like in the age of
giant
insects the Carboniferous period was one
of the most transformational periods in
the history of Earth the planet's land
masses were beginning to form the
supercontinent of Pangia extensive
swamps and warm humid forests dominated
the
landscape and giant insects weren't the
only huge creatures roaming the planet
there was also a vast array of marine
life like early forms of sharks and a
giant amphibian that would reach up to 6
ft
long now enough talking let's travel
back in time 300 million years ago and
dive in the Carboniferous
age now the first thing you'd probably
notice would be the giant insect likee
creatures one of the most iconic was the
Mega nura this insect resembled a
modern-day
dragonfly except with a major twist it
had a wingspan of up to 75
cm yeah scarier than that though it was
carnivorous hunting down other insects
and small
amphibians oh hopefully it doesn't come
for you so that thing is in the sky but
on land you'll have the arthr plura this
milliped like creature could grow up to
2 and 1/2 M long luckily it wouldn't go
after you it preferred munching on
decomposing vegetation hey before we
talk more about these giant insects
there's another giant issue we need to
worry about and that's our planet's
ecosystems and how important it is to
help them stick around till the end of
this video to check out an inspiring
project from the folks over at Planet
wild another creepy looking insect was
the pulos
Scorpius this was a giant scorpion that
mostly roamed the sampier areas of Earth
they could grow 70 cm
long there were also giant cockroaches
that grew to 10
cm and mayflies with 45 cm
wingspans so it's safe to say that you'd
have a lot to watch out for when you're
wandering around in this period but the
question is how did these insects get so
big anyway well you may have noticed as
you've been hanging around in the
Carboniferous age you feel a lot more
energetic and alert maybe you've had an
easier time running around this has to
do with the oxygen levels in your
current world research has estimated
that the atmospheric oxygen levels were
as high as 35% during this period
compare that to the 21% we breathe today
oxygen was one of the key factors in the
gigantism found in insects at the time
but why would this make them so
giant insects breathe differently from
other creatures insects don't have a
circulatory system to transport oxygen
instead it gets delivered directly to
their tissues through through a network
of tiny tubes called the trachea and the
more oxygen in the atmosphere the bigger
these insects are but there might be
more reasons why the insects grew to
this size another theory suggests that
the insects were forced to grow so large
due to oxygen
toxicity yeah as amazing as oxygen is
you can have too much of a good thing
too much oxygen in your body can create
what's known as free radicals these are
unstable molecules that can damage your
cells and even damage your
DNA in the case of our insects they were
forced to grow this big otherwise they'd
suffer oxygen toxicity growing larger
would slow down the rate of oxygen
absorption making it harder to suffer
from too much oxygen and the same could
happen to you the longer you hang out in
this period the higher oxygen levels
will cause you to experience nausea
respiratory issues and even some effects
on your nervous system now insects were
arguably the stars of this age but they
weren't the only things to experience
massive change during the Carboniferous
period this time was known as the coal
age that's because of the extensive coal
beds that formed after ancient forests
decade these coal beds are one of our
main sources of energy we're still using
them today
and a lot of the fruits and veggies you
find in the grocery store may be
descendants of plants from over 300
million years ago the Carboniferous
period saw the evolution of the first
seed bearing plants creating more
diverse ecosystems than we'd ever seen
before wait what's that over there kind
of looks like a
dinosaur oh hey little guy turns out
this wasn't a dyo just one of the first
first reptiles to ever appear but if you
stick around a couple of million more
years we'll enter the Mesozoic Era which
was known as the age of
dinosaurs speaking of change the
atmosphere was another part of Earth
that evolved during this period Earth
had a lush greenhouse-like climate when
you first arrived warm and humid
temperatures to support the swampy
forests we've been mucking about but as
the period progressed over for millions
of years the climate transitioned to
what's known as an ice house Earth State
the temperature would get significantly
lower and ice sheets would begin to form
mainly in the southern
hemisphere but why did this happen well
as we've been exploring this crazy
period earth's land masses have been
slowly coming together to form a
supercontinent known as Pangia and when
land mass is this big start to move it
can seriously affect ocean currents wind
patterns and Global Climate now the
rainforests have collapsed which has led
to a decline in the fauna and vegetation
that were previously
booming and with the rainforests in
Decline well that means oxygen levels
are being reduced before you know it our
massive insects start dying and going
extinct without the higher levels of
oxygen available to support their size
well these giant insects can't
survive the lower oxygen levels and a
drier climate have created a habitat
better suited for smaller
insects also happening at this point
early reptiles are starting to take over
making the landscape way more difficult
for the
[Music]
insects if time travel is possible why
haven't we met a single time traveler
yet and if we did meet one how would we
know they weren't faking
it what would their time machine look
like and how would it
operate would there be a set of rules
for time travelers to follow and what
would happen if they decided to break
them this is what if and here's what
would happen if you met a time traveler
in 1998 a gentleman by the name of John
ttor arrived from the future or so he
said in his timeline as he claimed
General Electric had managed to invent
time travel in the year
2034 he even showed and described his
time traveling device in great detail
and then ttor vanished as abruptly as he
appeared
did he finish his mission or was he real
at
all how could we
know if we were able to prove that
someone has traveled from a different
time it would be very cool for science
although it might overwrite Albert
Einstein's theory of
relativity Einstein approached time as a
fourth
dimension space is a three-dimensional
spectrum that provides us with length
width and height time offers
Direction together they form A Spacetime
Continuum and it can be affected by
gravity according to Einstein's theory
of relativity gravity is a curve in
SpaceTime and technically because space
and time are one gravity could Bend time
as well as space but you'd need
something really really big to notice
any changes in the movement of
time if you somehow managed to get
yourself close to a black hole like
Sagittarius A you'd be experiencing time
at half speed compared to people on
Earth this is because Sagittarius A
packs a mass of 4 Million Suns into an
indefinitely dense Point creating a very
strong gravitational field around
it another another way to travel in time
is to move really fast the closer you
get to the speed of light the slower
time passes for you if you were a
passenger on a train that somehow could
travel at 99% of the speed of light for
every year you spent on the train 223
years would have passed back at the
station that would make you a time
traveler into the future but what about
traveling back in time just like John
Tor said he
did Tor claimed that this little machine
is what made time travel possible in any
direction the c204 as he called it
allowed him to manipulate gravity with
the help of two micro singularities that
were packed
inside it also had gravity sensors to
lock the machine and time traveler in a
fixed place in
space ttor had this machine installed in
a car pretty much like the good old time
traveling DeLorean did but it would only
take him as far as 60 years from his
time how would you know that Tor was
actually traveling in time and not just
making it
up proving that someone really is a time
traveler might be even harder than time
travel
itself Time Travelers could make
predictions about the future show their
futuristic technology or even undergo
some genetic testing to support their
story maybe the best way to prove time
travel is real would be to take you with
them on their next
adventure of course there are easier
ways to prove the possibility of time
travel in 2009 the world famous
theoretical physicist Steven Hawking
threw a party not just any party but one
to which only future time travelers were
invited Hawking didn't send off
invitations until after the party he
believed that if travelers from the
future arrived before the invitation was
released that would prove that time
travel will become possible one day he
sat there waiting for hours but nobody
showed
up that doesn't mean time travel is
impossible there is a chance that time
travelers from the future will learn to
use wormholes or bridges in SpaceTime we
haven't seen one of those yet but the
theory of general relativity predicts
that they exist
the biggest problem with wormholes is
that they're microscopic and collapse
too quickly for a human traveler to go
through but maybe the reason nobody
attended Hawkings party is that time
traveling might not be that
precise maybe the guests from the future
did arrive but they were too late for
the party or maybe going back in time is
strictly prohibited for Time Travelers
because if they do they might change
their timeline
completely
perhaps they're just trying to avoid the
risk of spreading any diseases from the
far future onto
us or maybe the information about time
traveling is so highly classified that
only a few people would be trusted with
it maybe traveling back into time isn't
possible after all maybe time can only
move forward and never backwards maybe
John Tor was one big lie we have a few
more years until 2034 to find
out in a way we already have time
travelers In Our Lifetime astronauts on
the International Space Station are
moving at 8
km/s this makes them age slower although
the difference is measured in hundreds
of a second but if you're listening
you're invited to a reception for Time
Travelers hosted by Steven Hawking the
party will take place at the University
of Cambridge United Kingdom on June 28th
20 n no RSVP
required that's Steven Hawking he sure
was a Scamp wasn't he you know one thing
we didn't mention about traveling back
in time is that if you're an English
speaker like I am well you could really
only go back about 450 years before
you're unable to communicate with the
other English speakers of the day that's
because it was around the time of the
Great Vowel Shift that's when people
started pronouncing their vowels
differently before this time eyes were
were pronounced like e and U's were
pronounced like O's so the words sounded
completely different but they were
mostly the same words we'd be completely
lost but okay this is the point in the
show where I usually tell you about our
merch store yeah you can buy shirts like
this so that you can look super cool and
knowledgeable and so your friends can
come up to you and say oh no way I know
that what if show you like it too
amazing anyways no pressure but if you
want to look cool shop. underknown
do.com that's where you get
imagine a time of scientific and
mathematical
Innovation magic and fertile land
irrigated by the great Nile
River ancient Egypt was a successful and
intelligent civilization that lasted for
3,000
years what do you think your life would
be like if you were an Egyptian during
this time period
and let's pretend it's a good period no
droughts locusts plagues or famine for
you what kind of food would you eat how
were women
treated and did slaves build the
pyramids this is what if and here's what
would happen if you lived in ancient
Egypt ancient Egyptians believed in
strict social structure
depending on the class or trade you were
born into your life would be vastly
different the hierarchical Pyramid of
social status and wealth was composed of
slaves and
servants tenant Farmers Specialists like
sailors and
soldiers educational professionals and
finally the
elite who would you
be at the bottom of the social pyramid
were slaves they came from foreign lands
but were not of a single race and while
they could negotiate their contracts
they were still bonded laborers and
worked in exchange for food and
shelter at the very top of the pyramid
was the ruler who reigned over everyone
there were 300 rulers throughout ancient
Egypt's existence while we call them
pharaohs today that wasn't their actual
title in ancient
Egypt rulers did not necessarily have to
be men or Egyptian but they were seen as
divinely aons between the gods and the
people life would be drastically
different depending on your gender like
many ancient civilizations Egypt had
strict gender
roles but you still had the same legal
rights women could only own property and
live alone if they chose to however
marriage was seen as a social and
economic necessity no matter your gender
so if you lived in ancient Egypt you'd
probably be married and have a brood of
children you would live in a house built
of mud bricks with a stone oven and pits
dug into the ground for food
storage if you were an elite family then
lucky you as a nobleman or woman you
would be waited upon by your
servants after a breakfast of bread and
fruit the man of the house would take
his Chariot down to his estate on the
banks of the
Nile after touring the grounds and maybe
meeting with the estate overseer about
the year's Harvest you might take a
quick
nap once you're rested you would meet up
with a friend to hunt wild fowl on your
estate at home as a a woman you would
spend the day supervising plans for a
banquet before the banquet begins you
would Adorn yourself with gold and
semi-precious stones to further show
your wealthy
status now you're ready to greet your
guests as they arrive in chariots and
litters which were wheeless enclosures
carried on the shoulders of
servants nobleman or woman you Feast on
Geese duck fish ox and gazelle followed
by grapes figs dates and
melons once the party is over you head
to bed while your servants clean
up life as a farmer is not nearly as
Grand if you're a man you spend the day
working in the fields and tending to
cattle or
ducks on tax day you would pack up some
of your Harvest and bring it to the
temple as payment for the land land if
you're a woman you spend the day
grinding wheat making bread and raising
children for food you mainly eat bread
beer garlic and if you're fortunate a
little bit of
meat maybe you're neither part of the
elite or a farmer but a pyramid
Builder you wouldn't be a slave but you
would live a life of hard labor
you would be one of 10,000 devoted
workers since it took 30 years to build
one pyramid you would probably work on
the same Monument for your entire
[Music]
life which would be shorter than your
fellow ancient Egyptians because of all
that hard
labor at least you get to eat meat
regularly and get an honorable burial
once you die
no matter your status you would worship
several thousand gods and for fun you
would play board games such as men or
Senate to pass some free
time overall the quality of your life
would drastically depend on your ruler
and the time
period there were three periods of
prosperity and two periods of
instability during this
civilization fear of famine caused by
droughts or locusts was a constant
threat but you'd still have better luck
living a good life in ancient Egypt than
you would in the Middle
Ages this is the world 200 million years
ago no cell phones electricity or even
other humans would you be able to
survive in this new world could you get
yourself a pet dinosaur wait dinosaurs
are here okay maybe this won't be so bad
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you were alive 200 million
years ago the world was pretty different
during the late Triassic period one of
the most notable differences is this
right here this is Pangia a
supercontinent containing different
parts of today's world there's Australia
down south North America in the
Northwest and Eurasia in the East all
interconnected it would take you a while
but in theory you could walk from
California to France you won't see the
Hollywood Walk of Fame or see the Eiffel
Tower as they don't exist yet what would
you
see the first thing you'd notice as
you're traveling across Pangia are all
the dinosaurs running about you won't
have to worry about dinosaurs such as
the Delong that weigh only 11 kg they
won't pose much of a threat but watch
out for the melanorosaurus who has a
height of 12 m and would find you to be
a tasty snack scientists say that the
late Triassic period was the dawn of the
first dinosaurs dinosaurs of all sizes
would be everywhere you'd also see some
other crazy creatures you've never seen
before and some that may remind you of
animals you see today this species known
as the drepanosaurus with its
reptile-like skin and arched back might
be one of the first versions of birds to
ever exist the Triassic period was an
incredibly important 50 million years of
evolution a time with not a lot of
competition between species since just
prior to this period 70% of Earth's
creatures were wiped out in a mass
extinction event many of the animals at
the time were able to thrive and grow
without having to be constantly wary of
other Predators the further you travel
Inland into Pangia you'll notice the
massive weather changes the outer edges
of the supercontinent may be full of
lush forests and green grass but the
further you go in that begins to change
scientists suspect that much of P Anga
was a dry desert Wasteland that's
because the land mass was so large that
the interior wouldn't have received the
cooling effects of the ocean speaking of
which the ocean known as panasa
surrounded all of Pangia and covered 70%
of Earth's surface this ocean was
extremely deadly it could easily produce
super hurricanes and monsoons and due to
its massive size they could gain enough
momentum to hit Pangia with potentially
fatal weather Pangia was just beginning
to separate 200 million years ago if you
were able to stick around a few million
more years for the Jurassic period
That's when you'd truly see dinosaurs
Thrive imagine if you could take in all
of human history in the blink of an eye
well from the first steps out of the
slime to the first steps on the moon
that's exactly where we are in Cosmic
terms but in that short amount of time
we've done quite a bit what would you
see if you traveled 1 billion years into
the
past did Earth ever look like a giant
slush
ball how far back would you have to go
to see the first
humans and are we already going
extinct this is what if and here's what
would happen if you went 1 billion years
into the
[Music]
past in a sense we're alltime Travelers
we travel into the future at the rate of
1 second per second but if you want to
go backward in time you'll need to go
faster than the speed of light that's
according to Einstein or maybe your time
machine would jump through
wormholes a hypothetical tunnel that
connects two different points in
SpaceTime however you decide to travel
through the jumbled mess of time you'll
see the effects and then the causes of
the most powerful forces that shaped our
world you might leave wondering how many
times did the earth
freeze as you watch History unfold or
refold or whatever you you might be
surprised at the toll Humanity has taken
on this planet in such a short amount of
time if you start in 2021 and move
backward you would watch the sixth mass
extinction event happening right now
known as the hallene extinction we are
currently living through one of the most
destructive periods of our time caused
by human
activity as humans destroy coral reefs
and rainforests
the numerous wildlife and plants that
depend on these ecosystems die with them
according to the international Union for
the conservation of nature 67% of
endangered species could be extinct in
100 years and since most of these
extinctions are
undocumented we won't even know about
what we've lost until it's gone maybe
not even then visit the 18th and 19th
centur and you could watch the pollution
created by the Industrial Revolution
reversed back into the Smoke Stacks
cities would shrink down and return to
their Roots as rural
farmlands while this would let you see
the explosion of the human race in terms
of population and pollution if you want
to retrace our first steps you'll need
to go back
farther tour the planet 200,000 years
ago and you would Witness the arrival of
our species Homo sapiens jump back 7
million years to Northern Chad and the
oldest known species of humans could
stroll right by you known as
theanthropos
jadensis this mysterious Link in our
chain looked aplike but was the first to
walk upright he seems friendly
enough but travel to 60 millon years ago
and you'll see the first primates emerge
from the humid rainforests of Asia okay
step back to 65 million years ago and
you'd find yourself under the giant
asteroid that created a global
Extinction event the impact caused a
tsunami and filled the air with dust and
debris the crash also set off massive
volcanic eruptions across the world with
the sun blacked out and the land
flooding the last of the dinosaurs died
out but without this event mammals like
us may never have taken over the
planet go back 130 million years and
you'll see the first flowers
bloom as you travel 200 million years
back in time you'll witness the breakup
of
Pia the mass of land that will become
the
continents as the land breaks apart the
lava eruptions will be so massive they
kill almost 80% of the species on Earth
okay keep going back another 20 million
years and watch the first early mammals
small and nocturnal crawl around in the
dark and if you go back to 230 million
years ago you could watch the early
dinosaurs walk for the first time on two
legs before that can happen though the
Earth has to go through what would be
known as the great dying also called the
perian extinction 95% of all species on
Earth died but you could also watch the
earth's land masses come together to
form Pangia now you could take a walk
from Argentina to China but things get
interesting around 375 million years ago
you would watch watch marine animals
walking onto land for the first time
maybe you would see a talic which looks
like a salamander mixed with a fish this
strange creature would later evolve into
mammals and
amphibians but just like every species
you saw before this growth doesn't
happen without a cost and now we're at
the first Extinction event the or
division Extinction occurs when ice
sheets spread from the polar caps into
the
oceans almost 70% of all sea life died
off during this planewide freeze over
460 million years
ago okay keep going back and you could
see how life started underwater called
the Cambrian explosion the lineage of
most of the species on our planet today
can be traced back to this Milestone but
but scientists are still unsure how this
unique event happened between 635 and
850 million years ago the earth froze
over twice once for almost 60 million
years and the next time for 15 million
years one Theory suggests that the Earth
was only covered in a thin film of ice
allowing the sun's Rays to seep through
and plant the SE Seeds of Life Below but
go back 1 billion years in history and
you'll be surprised to find well not a
lot during this time red algae are
forming spores to reproduce cells are
coming together to form larger organisms
life on Earth is microscopic and not
very threatening but nothing has been
more vicious to our planet in such a
short amount of time as humans
but maybe humans will set things right
eventually there could be a change in
our planet or our hearts that might set
our future on a different path or maybe
like the dinosaurs and
neandertals we would just be replaced by
something
else so let's take our time machine and
find
out what if you traveled 1 billion years
into the
future well that's a story for another
what
[Music]
if okay that's it for today's tour a
tumultuous twirling Tempest traversing
the terrain and time of terrafirma hope
you enjoyed we'll be back soon with
another what
if
if you traveled 10,000 years into the
future what would planet Earth look
like would most of its surface be
covered in
volcanoes or would it be frozen in
ice what if you traveled even further to
1 million years in the future future
would all of the oceans have
evaporated or would it have become one
giant water
world okay now what about 1 billion
years